I don't know anyway we're talking one
before that probably depressing no drugs
on the podcast I saw someone get coke
Bowdoin blown into their ass no have I
ever told that story
let's hear [ __ ] after this show we
like went back to his people's apartment
and I can't use any names or like any
unit so great it just sounds like a lie
yeah yeah hung out with these guys and
then that's someone else someone who
isn't me a straw and someone else's ass
no we're sitting there and there's coke
on the table and someone's like someone
says yo you gonna blow it into my ass
and I'm like I'm sitting on the couch
like why it's gotta be a joke right
is this male/female it was a guy and a
girl so a female asking a male yeah okay
and I was like there's gotta be a joke
right
I've never seen some [ __ ] like that
before I'm from [ __ ] Calgary there's
no one cocaine in Calgary yeah and and
she guys again for sure
he's like gets a little straw out like
cuts it whatever and she just [ __ ]
drops trou right there turns around
bends over
he puts dips of straw in coke like take
some and puts it in her ass and [ __ ]
blows and then he's like alright now do
the same to me no dude both of her fans
he turns around drops trou bends over
she bloke was cooking a hit in the
middle of [ __ ] living room it's a
love story in the MS net like Romeo
Juliet the modern day yeah the coke
version yeah yeah definitely modern
yeah then they want to got matching face
tattoos after exactly fell in love yeah
that's wild yeah so what's her name
I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm not gonna dog
these people right now I mean you want
me to doctor you just saying that just
for science purposes no no I was
actually a shitty way of implying that
you that was you getting the coke of
your ass that's completely missed the
word ad Joe yeah terrible bad joke but
also bad receiving of the joke oh my
well that's that's [ __ ] crazy it was
crazy I mean like I don't know how crazy
that is
I don't know it depends what kind of
circles you run and Grey's for me to see
that [ __ ] yeah I've never seen some [ __ ]
like that my entire life
yeah I've been around drugs like a
I've never seen anyone even come close
to blowing it in each other's [ __ ] I
don't know man I feel like 18 year olds
no matter what generation always have a
one-up yeah always have I was yeah it's
like did
that's nothing dude you want to talk
about straws and asses I had my boy
shotgun ayahuasca into my dick hole yeah
a nice trip for nine days straight
[ __ ] no big deal NBD yeah it was like
nothing bruh my girl took a [ __ ]
bendy straw like out of a little sippy
cup like three loops dude yeah filled it
all the way all three loops with coke
yeah blew it into her ass that's
whatever dude
I peeled my toenails off one by one and
then put LSD strips on the wounds oh wow
that one got me ha ha that's [ __ ] up
Edie dude I'm still tripping from that
[ __ ] oh that I feel I felt that one that
was disgusting this rapidly move on
rapidly more yeah I lined my [ __ ]
retainer my Invisalign that might [ __ ]
my parents first of all took my
Invisalign lined it with LSD went to
sleep with it then I put coke on my
teeth because I grind my teeth in my
sleep yeah and so I'm grinding my teeth
with the coke on my teeth while sucking
down that LSD that's pretty cool yeah
that feel I don't know woke up a month
later hmm that's kind of cool I mean
it's nothing like what I did no no with
the lemons what did you do well I let
lemons soak in Molly water for a month
mmm and really ferment and stuff like
that and then I [ __ ] squirted them in
my eyes call that one the supreme patty
I rolled for that sick did I rolled for
[ __ ] I mean ten years ten years
sick dude yeah I'm brain dead that's
fine yeah it's fire dude being brain
dead his lit yeah he's [ __ ] lit I
mean I guess that's cool yeah it's
whatever
[Music]
it's not as hard as me my boys go what
are you what are you guys do dog you
don't even know yeah what is it y'all
you know like you know like nerds huh
like the people or the nah the candy
like the candy okay yeah they imagine
that but it's all meth rocks okay I'm
saying huh okay we make like bracelets
out of that yeah yeah Sam uh-huh that's
how we get them into the festival right
uh-huh
now in the middle of festival yeah we
just take the bracelets I just eat the
whole [ __ ] bracelet dawg nice yeah
that's pretty cool trip hard yeah [ __ ]
everyone up at the festival we literally
fight the entire festival we shut down
EDC last year's run so much PCP we got
shot up by the SWAT team and bullets
didn't hurt us because we are so high on
[ __ ] meth that we were literally
invincible both skin yeah that's a crazy
side effect of piece of you that people
don't you don't you turn into t1000 from
[ __ ] terminator yeah exactly you can
walk in Wolverine you actually it does
damage you but you heal heal yeah that
was [ __ ] awesome nine [ __ ] bros
just on PCP fighting all of EDC
everyone's like freaking out trying to
stop them they just can't
oh just walking down the whole crowd
that's like starting from the middle out
it just starts to spread
[Music]
this I got some fun
these are Dustin home
these are nothing